like when i'm looking at jt i'm not like
why should i look at i'm just looking at
them i have another question for you for
the room
um so it turns out that when people have
thoughts there's uh there are people
that hear the thoughts there's an actual
voice in their head and there are people
who don't hear the thoughts it's more of
like an abstract thing in their head
where do you land on that oh i hear the
thoughts you hear there's a very clear
voice maybe that's why you're very quick
on your feet when you respond like your
brain is attached to your mouth what
about you wait so it's thoughts in your
head you hear the thoughts in your head
like that when you have a thought do you
hear of your own voice in your head is
there a voice in that that is expressing
those thoughts
i don't think so mine either i don't
know yeah i don't know what's going on i
don't hear my voice i hear a voice
though yeah
whose voice but there are people like
him who their thoughts are as you can
hear i can hear it my oh
it's not my voice it's somebody else's
voice whose voice is it located
who's that it's just that's the voice
have you ever heard of this george look
at gianni
i just learned about it like a few weeks
ago too i'll argue about the voice not
another voice will come in and tell that
voice to stop okay it's a different
voice let me hear what it says it's like
the one voice of like we're in trouble
things are not looking good this is bad
and then another voice we go hey you're
staying out of this we're taking the
wheel right now i do the same [ __ ]
thing too i do the same [ __ ] thing
too i argue against myself yeah yeah
yeah so you hear it yeah i hear two
things and this is a real thing i'm not
making this even as a joke right so this
this happens every [ __ ] day
like what was i also i was watching it's
so stupid this is the honest truth and
and this is
real but and i don't i can't believe i
am i'm even admitting this
i wake up today and i go on instagram
and i said so i'm doing this movie with
johnny knoxville right now and mo ammer
and theo vaughn
in a softball movie just by the way can
i just say this out loud that
johnny knoxville is an amazing [ __ ]
actor
i he's [ __ ] blowing my mind in this
[ __ ] movie
yeah i just want to throw that out there
anyway so i met mo ammer and so today
today i was going on instagram and i see
mo ammer's page and he's hanging out
with the rock
you know i mean and all these guys right
and he has a new show coming up like you
know i just told you a lot
a24 is doing it nice and it all in my
head i'm just like ah
look at you
loser
right and then this other ghost
it's a very aggressive voice i go shut
the [ __ ] up dude you're doing good too
right so there's always so i combat it i
really do
both voices but i have to have both you
know i mean because it's like um i think
the second voice is who i really am
[Music]
right and this first one is some damaged
part of me that's like
you know i mean this old part of me that
i want to change
you know what i mean do you want to yeah
100 the first voice kept you safe or the
second voice kept you safe when things
were difficult yes but you don't need it
now so you can do away with it and
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah do you have two
voices so your that second voice is yeah
that's what a therapist told me about my
second voice yeah yeah yeah yeah how
about you you have two you know voices
no i was thinking about more because i
was trying to think i
i
i'm more of an introvert i think so i
get lost in thought in my head and then
when i'm talking to someone if i let
thoughts go on in my head then i i can't
i need i need to process that
um so when i'm talking to someone i
can't have anything happening it needs
to just flow
um so that's why
i need to sort of sit back and take
things in a little bit more and then in
terms of voices in my head i definitely
have that if i see if like jealousy
comes up
um so you do get jealousy oh big time do
you get jealousy yeah yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah and so how do you combat the
jealousy
i i i think i'm able to sort of uh
process you know
push it towards motivation you know as
sort of like uh i i i get competitive
but i get competitive with myself
okay yeah yeah same thing i think like
you're
if if you're jealous of someone they're
actually kind of helping you because
they're motivating you to be better so i
always think about like gangs in new
york with like build a butcher and like
amsterdam it's like they're both making
each other stronger so your enemy's kind
of your best friend because they're
they're making you rise up a little bit
did they say that the knife sharpens
iron trippens i have sharpened
that's exactly how that's exactly
exactly yeah yeah it's like
it's basically it's like
i have this other voices like when
somebody [ __ ] me over where i'm like
instead of like getting really angry i
just go i'll show you
yeah yeah
is that healthy or yeah it's great
what do you mean
it motivates me like you'll see one
you'll see one day
i get really hard on myself
that's how i